wait a second wait a second game we got
that Ru garbage.com to talk about before
we get to the episode it's your One-Stop
shop for everything are you garbage we
got teas we got lighters we got anything
you need just these and lighters but
still and they're not real Zippos either
just zip o s because that's what we're
saying uh also you get tickets to your
live shows gang coming up we have
Louisville tickets still available get
those and we have Cleveland and Columbus
and we're about to announce the second
leg of the tour sign up sign the email
list get involved baby we're having a
good time love yous welcome so another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that at
the group to be classy yeah they're just
a big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here at hoodies in
the new edition baby she's in the
kitchen got a fresh pot of gravy on the
stove in honor of our special guest here
today should have when I told her he was
coming in she was drooling up I don't
know it's got tight little body on them
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he is an international businessman and
he is not to be trifled with in the
Board Room or the bedroom ladies give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are real
cooking baby closing on 150 000
subscribers over there on a YouTube you
check it out yeah and obviously I'd be
remiss if I didn't mention the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon dot com slash are you
garbage baby check it out it's a party
over at air gang doing a good job over
there and how about the second greatest
website of all time are you garbage.com
do yourself a favor all your Dickies all
your all your merch whatever you need
over there plus we're going to start
doing taxes next tax season
it's like the new H R Block okay and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer ex short and air the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen on the Toby Camp hey what up
dude what up T-Bone man when this guy
comes in he just sets the vibe off yeah
he's a good dealer he's chaos as some
would say I like how you leaned into the
a yeah very New York yeah you know we
got
[Music]
yeah getting the long hair ain't lying
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly special guests back with us
again today he's family at this goddamn
point we love him he's Italian what are
you gonna do it's not the way it goes
he's a good kid though and we love him
host of Chrissy chaos and he's on tour
right now you know him you love him and
he's going to be at the Radio City Music
Hall the end of the summer not to
mention the theater at Madison Square
Garden following that give it up for
Christmas
[Music]
it was magical and I appreciate because
you started off saying you know the
Italian got the sauce on tight little
body I think the fans might have but
they can initially Mateo Lane but but
guess what even gayer Chrissy D is here
I love the new digs it feels good in
here it just it it's it's you it's
success and I like it it's one of those
things even Toby Toby's one of those
guys he looks dirty and clean at the
same time I can never figure it out but
he's in everybody's improved we got it's
just congratulations guys my favorite
part of the studio the carpet thank you
shout out to local 2287 out there on the
island yeah coming in for a little
sidewalk yeah the boys came in I will
take care of that I assume you're a side
work guy you like throwing a little work
to the boys I do I don't mind I'm a big
Tipper I like throwing work to the boys
that's not what I heard by the way I
know I know we talked about it I know we
talked about it on the last episode
there's somebody spreading rumors at Joe
the Rose's bar that I don't tip and
pay everybody out yeah I've got
everybody out here I'm just gonna own
the bar yeah here's your Severance get
out of here get out of here so um but
yeah I'm not actually even though I
appear to be I'm not a handy guy I was
never taught the tools because Dad was
in the clink so I was never taught for
tools
and and but believe it or not my family
Jasmine you know my girl mother and my
kids she can build she'll build you a
house if you're gonna have her come in
here she would have built your house she
would have got you on the spin bike she
would have been she would have put up
everything I would have lost a couple of
pounds yeah she's a pelotonin she's good
with her hands and that's just the roles
that listen gender roles in in today's
day and more little flip-flopped in your
house more and more guys are just you
know I'm I'm the creative fun one and
Mom just puts her head down and does the
work does the work yeah throw you a
cabinet together in two minutes two
minutes yeah while dinner's cooking yep
do you have a handyman around a house or
does she do it like if you're like who
hangs a picture who does that we got we
got our guys showing the contractor
shout out Sean the contractor I've never
seen a contractor.com
he's got a new merch drop too yeah show
on thecontractor.com Good Guys tall kid
um I've never seen him I've never seen
him without um he's still you know he
doesn't go with the airless Wireless
airpods he still wears the Bluetooth but
around us here with the connection in
the back I don't trust that yeah like
young guy too no 40 years old okay he
still wears those but he'll build
anything he's actually out out and he's
there right now he's building um he's
building us say a little outdoor kitchen
in the yard for the summer very nice
nice very nice the last time I think we
talked you were talking about getting
rid of the deep end in the pool did you
do that we reconfigured the whole pool
we got we got we reached it had to be
expensive yes
it cost me it cost me a bunch of them
Jimmy the handyman wasn't doing that
yeah I I think I overshot it cost too
much that's why I'm asking you guys off
there what are you doing for Merch
because I mean I came in here
immediately what are you paying this
place you got going for Merch what are
your road deals looking like what agency
you in yeah I got questions because uh
what the pool cost about 40 000 t-shirts
easy and um and and it was one of those
here's what I've learned you ready for
this you're ready for I've learned I've
come in with some with some knowledge
some life now you've been very you have
while you are a chaotic gentleman yes we
just did Chrissy chaos and you are you
do have a very
good grasp of your life
change from where you were you always
had a good head on your shoulders
obviously but a little more chaotic
you're a little more disciplined now a
little bit more difficult yeah life hits
you on the face well I think what
happens is you get hit in the face a
little bit with life and you start to
say well how the hell am I going to
extend I can't be getting on a plane
going to Omaha at 53 years old I can't
do it so I got to make these choices now
but I've realized if I put in a 20 000
Grill that's what it is yeah yeah so I
dropped a quick 80k on the kids playset
they so so so that'll keep me out of
Missouri for a little while yeah but all
those decisions have kind of you know
spent too much money what happened was I
got used to you know I I was like oh I
need the house I need to and then I
realize I don't need you know I have the
I had this big house and my dog the
biggest thing for me was mine look he
got rid of it you still haven't I still
got it oh yeah I'm still paying big and
um and so but my daughter she was like
you know when we lived in the apartment
in Bay Ridge we were all close together
we were hanging out we would sit on the
stoop together with our neighbor first
blah blah so my daughter had no windows
in her bedroom that always bothered me I
was like she's got no windows I'm doing
okay now I got to get my daughter a
window and then we move her to this to
the house beautiful house great very
nice house great great neighbors but now
you're on like a little island like
we're literally on a hill by ourselves
and so you think that that's what you
want and then my daughter the very first
night she was there sleeping in the new
house I was like look at this baby look
at all this sunlight coming in look at
this and she was like I don't want a
window I miss my old room and she's
still a year and a half later it's like
I missed my old room I hate all these
windows they scare me and I'm and now
it's like I'm in this house but it's
like got my stepson up there on the
video game put her in the closet what
are you doing I know I'd seal that
window up seriously hey you don't want a
window all right yeah bang we have
plenty of room down the basement now
you're going back to Bay Bridge yeah I'm
[__] put her next in a hot water
heater for a couple of nights yeah
she'll be loving the Windows so yeah so
so now I got this house and I love it
and all that but but I'm like you know
there's it's not out of the question
Christy D might pull a while moving
selling the next two years and go back
to Bay Ridge or even come to I want to
be back I like you like the tight the
close knit I like close snitch yeah
get in a house or something over there
no I don't know if I'm a house guy
because you know everything's always
breaking I don't know how to fix stuff
yeah I'm not I'm realizing I'm not a
house guy I'm an apartment kid I like
being in an apartment kids ain't gonna
like that they're gonna think you're
tanking no I know right I swear to God
I'm doing the theater we don't need to
pull look we can we got the Hudson River
we'll jump in I got the wrench to the
fire plug what are we doing yeah I know
I know but uh yeah but you know I'm I'm
basically I'm I'm creating this
narrative now to preemptively say that
I'm bleeding money in my business so I
gotta sell that [__] house so you put
you did finish finish the pool the pool
is finished as a matter of fact shout
out my guy Armando Armando the pool guy
he opened up the pool today today the
pool was open so yeah so now [__] that's
an early opening it's an early yeah we
went early opening you need the business
well that we need the business and you
know and again I sprung for the heaters
so the gas bill's coming up so you tell
me you could go home tonight
no jacuzzi though right no jacuzzi we
figured we can heat it up we can heat
this sucker up all the way to 98 Degrees
yeah
so so you know home tonight take a nice
little soak I can but see here's the
issues though now now the pool's opening
right so you think oh it's beautiful
it's great but now what's my first
thought ah now we got to put a fence in
because I my when I got this pool last
year my kid wasn't walking the baby now
the baby runs all over she's almost two
so you gotta put a fence because you
already have a fence a second fence you
put those net fences up you have to
because you can't take a risk sure and
then it's like you know we could have I
didn't need the pool I had a friend when
I was first buying looking at the house
I love this I had a friend and he goes
I'm telling you he's had a homeowner for
20 years he goes you don't I kept
looking for a house for the pool he goes
just get a house with a backyard you
don't need a pool like now they really
want a pool it's great we want our own
pool he was like I'm telling you if you
want a pool live with your house a
little bit live in it for a few years
and then if you really want the pool
when the kids get older put a pool in
and I should have listened to him
because now all I do now from now until
we close it I will just constantly worry
when I'm not there yeah is one of my
kids in the pool right and so I've
created so sometimes like you create
these issues that you don't need to
create when you know keep it simple
stupid is like a good method just to
live life in any single way if you just
and I'm learning that not the hard way
because not saying it's hard but I am
feeling like you are creating problems
for yourself I didn't need these things
I thought I needed sure you're going to
wind up with a cousin out there on
permanent lifeguard Duty yeah seriously
I already I already have I'll get the
chair and everything yeah that'd be all
right yeah yeah I know well because you
know it's it's one of those things where
I'll take a couple of shifts yeah if
you're throwing some cash yeah yeah why
the hell oh if I can see Chris in a
two-piece
I don't mind if I do
try to seduce me yeah let me give them
out to mouth yeah yeah my dad he's at
the house he's staying for a month I
just saw you took him to the [__]
Knicks game and it looked
well it was here's thing I got a couple
of questions about that a little jealous
by the way although I'm not a Knicks fan
he's met A-Rod didn't you all right so I
did it so what happened was is I walked
in with my pops I always go in through
there's a there's a guy a shout out big
Dan always gets me the tickets works for
the team uh great guy you know he puts
me you get the you get the pay for the
tickets you get the you got to increase
him though I try to grease them they
don't they don't MSG doesn't take any
grease they may make it very clear they
should be rolling out the red carpet for
you got the theater coming up true but
they but but then so here's what
happened is I'm gonna still have to join
up yeah but you're doing a flyer in his
room for me yeah and so I don't get one
Chrissy so normally we go in to the to
our entrance and you know it's the you
get in you go up to the owner's Suite
then they bring you down it's either
Courtside you're telling me you got the
hook up like that you know I got the
hookup like that's crazy you zoom out
from where you were as a New York you
saw a playoff game for free free baby
walked in the owner's sweet walked in
the ownership you as a as a 12 year old
knew your kid you are living the dream
of most crazy yeah that's crazy I've
always wanted like that and that's why I
brought my dad because I'm like I get
these up my dad and I you know the first
basketball game ever went uh I ever went
to was in 1994 we saw Shaquille O'Neal
we sat in the on the magic we saw and we
sat up in the rafters and it was great
but now it's like we've we've moved down
a little by little I always take my pops
but that's amazing it's interesting we
go first of all we're in the elevator
with Chris Rock right we're getting out
in this private do you know Mr Rock like
I said hello to him but he just looked
at me and then you know and then so you
know my dad's in there and my dad you
know just quietly because again he knows
comedy but he's getting older he goes is
that Chappelle I was like I was like no
it's Chris Rock and he was like oh okay
so I like his old stuff yeah yeah so so
I get off no you get off the elevator if
you get off the elevator on like the
fourth floor that's where the owner's
Suite is and that's where they got free
food free drinks and it's great all the
celebr big celebrities all that are up
there and so you go and usually eat your
food get your drinks and and then they
somebody from the MSG staff will take
you down to your seats like they escort
you it's got the life so I so I'm
thinking that's what I got right I mean
like oh my God I'm walking I walk up the
elevator with Chris Rock like I'm like
I'm supposed to be where he is we walk
it to the owner's Suite that hey Mr Rock
and whoever I go up I'm like hey how are
you and then you know they know my name
because I've been there so much they go
hey the guy goes uh he goes you're not
in
there oh and I was like put the slider
back yeah yeah oh no it's funny you say
that maybe 12 bucks for that code my dad
because it's all free food my dad had
like a [__] prime rib on one plate
and he had he had a full plate of
asparagus on the other you got that far
in there he was already in line yeah
well they you know they said listen
nobody has to put anything back but get
the [__] out of here they're like you're
in the other street so they take us down
to the Delta Suite which is great is
nice but you got to pay for the food you
got to pay for the drinks and I get it
listen I get it listen listen Delta's
got it it's it you know yeah everybody's
asking your dad where he got the prime
rib yeah
so I mean you know you go in there you
got you know listen I get in the big
owner Suite it's the players you have
Ben Stiller you have Dwyane Wade in
there you have a rod you have Michael J
fox you don't belong in there they were
in there hanging out I'm sure they were
it's a big that's the big those are the
Courtside garyvee Jack Harlow they're
all in nice so I got not not asked to
leave but he's gotta like that garyvee's
kind of like that that and then and then
they so they take me out and we go to
Delta club which again is fun we get to
our seats all of a sudden we're sitting
down I get somebody gives me a noogie
which I haven't got I thought it was one
of my uncles back from the dead it turns
out to be Stavros Stavros and Sam Morrow
sitting we were seat 16 17 they were 18
19. exactly yeah we posted a pic and we
had I got to be honest with you there
was something I thought you guys were
all together the most fun I've had at a
sporting event the most fun at a
sporting event was was that night
watching that game we just had so much
fun again sometimes going back to you
know the kind of same analogy with the
big house and you think you want all the
fancy stuff sitting in the fancy court
side see don't get me wrong if you're
listening to big I want to go I love to
I love it but to sit with the crowd with
the actual Knicks fans with your boys
with your boys with your father no
celebrities no big business owners just
actual fans that paid that energy in
there was amazing I was like this is I I
want I like this how far back were you
so so nice to get some love from the
peeps
I know I got hit and then and then when
I get in there you know I started
getting the props and all that and then
people started noticing Starbucks and
sandwiches but let's keep it here right
now we're here yeah we're looking up at
the owner's box like yeah the only thing
that made me feel better is we were
sitting in section 108 and granted he
was closer but still not Courtside down
the order Street I saw Andrew Schultz I
said if Andrew Schultz is again in the
office then I ain't get in and I feel
better yeah I said if shelter's in the
Delta Club that's where I got to be 100
you have too no
prime rib sandwich no schultzy knew
Schultz yeah the Schultz no no he knows
he schultzy know schultzy would never be
in that situation I was in schultzy he
knows he reads the room you're like a
yeah you're like a big dumb idiot I'm a
big dummy I walk like an [__] Schultz
he did the right move yes he wasn't the
own street but he did descend from the
rafters right into his seat like like
Rihanna he came right down and it was so
he knows and and so Schultz is a smart
kid so I walked into not a trap because
again it's all you know it was amazing I
really appreciate MSG people giving me
those I just I was happy to be in the
building that's amazing but it was funny
to just think I could follow Chris well
I'm like I'm assuming I'm in Chris
rockstrom and like no you're not yeah
yeah you're down there with the openers
yeah yeah
but my dad doesn't know my dad and then
you know what what's awesome we're
sitting down he's got the prime rib and
all that takes a few bites feels bad so
he puts it back and then guess what we
went to the Delta Club cheeseburgers we
have cheeseburgers he loved them and he
was like that was the best one of the
best cheeseburgers I ever had there you
go your dad on the sauce at all is he
drinking at all no he's never had a
drink my dad's soberly my dad's been
sober from not even sober he just
doesn't drink he's never drank what's
the setup over at the house when he
stays he got his own kind of like room
they got the guest room yeah is there a
first floor guest room he's upstairs
first getting older right well yeah it's
a first floor guest room and he's been
telling me for the last few months
because you know the internet I did the
intermittent fasting he did the
intermittent fasting he's lost 40 pounds
he weighs 211. he said he hasn't been
[__] he goes I haven't been 211 since
I've been intimate with your mother
they got divorced in 86.
1986 they got divorced so he hasn't been
he hasn't been 211 since then and he
goes they're always telling me for the
last few weeks when I get you're gonna
see how I move I go because he would he
couldn't go up and down stairs he fall
he couldn't go up anything and then we
get he gets there
immediately comes into the house he goes
let me show you can go down the basement
falls down the stairs of the basement
just right
open on the steps
how is he as far as the house guest any
issues the toilet seat up this stuff
piles around what he does undies or
something no you know what no undies but
he comes in he'll come out no shirt and
sit at the table for breakfast no
problem just no shirt on that's old
school no shirt with his chains on he
doesn't care deal no no he's he's clean
sometimes he misses he pees on the floor
a little bit but he's getting older that
hey it happens we clean it right up no
problem that's why we got the Swiffer
jet there you go and he's got carte
blanche right when you come down in the
middle of the night to get a glass of
water he's in there having a sandwich
whatever you want whatever you want he's
intermittent fast
yeah he ate he ate the kids um the kids
got those gogurts he ate the Lance
Gogurt yesterday they didn't have any
for lunch and he is no apology he's like
well I needed the Goku I got diabetes I
need the Sugar Rush
yeah so it's okay let's talk about
ladder ladder ladder ladder hey you
don't know when you're gonna kick the
bucket do you nah unless you got
something planned for me ah no I have no
idea but gang you don't want to leave
the family holding the bag do yourself a
favor get a little term life insurance
over there or a ladder because it could
happen at any moment and you want to
have a little bit of insurance 100
digital no needles no doctors when you
apply for up to three million dollars in
government there ain't even paperwork
for they're giving out 3 million with no
paperwork these guys are Bonkers uh you
just got it twice you just get your
phone or the H Foley and H moly each got
it covered uh just get your phone on
your laptop answer a few quick questions
about your health ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved so you
choose what level of coverage you want
baby there's no hidden fees and you can
cancel at any time you'll even get a
full refund if you cancel within the
first 30 days so go to latterlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladderlife.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it folks get a
pen get a pencil write it down do
whatever you got to do get some damn
life insurance
Kim Let's talk about Aura frames Aura
Aura Aura love that or frames baby yeah
Best In The Biz gang do you take about a
million photos don't let them sit on
your phone or get lost in your files
what if you can have a place where you
can have those photos in one gorgeous
frame well now you can with the
connected frame from Aura name the best
digital photo frame by wire cutter the
strategist and featuring hundreds of
gifts guides Aura frames are guaranteed
to make Mom or Grandma smile yeah baby
and that Mother's Day is coming up shove
one of these at the bird and tell her to
zip it everybody post pictures you send
them over they all display for Nana for
Gaga for Mima your pipa whoever they all
get to see it got one in the kitchen we
keep our eyes on the baby it's fantastic
I gave one to Denise the piece I said
take it I sent her pictures of my b-hole
invite as many people as you want I'll
be sending a couple are away too and the
free advert to add their photos to the
frame you never know what fun or
embarrassing memories you'll get to
relive right now Aura has a great deal
from other Thursday listeners can save
on the perfect gift by visiting
orframes.com garbage that's
aurauraframes.com garbage use the code
garbage take up to 30 off plus free
shipping on their best selling Carver
frames the deal ends on May 14th so
don't wait terms and conditions applied
to it and we were walking yeah it was
pouring rain yeah pouring rain the other
day walking from the Knicks game we're
walking three blocks four three four
blocks from the garden to the parking
because again I think you know I got the
[__] parking but not the good one not
the work that's true we got you know six
blocks down okay at least we got the
parking and we're walking that's on the
arm too that's on the arm oh nice play
they don't [__] around and they and then
I got the same hookup with the Yankees
and the Mets too if you guys ever want
to get into that I don't like going to
baseball yeah
Yankees
Yankees Mets Knicks Rangers I can do I
used to be Islanders but my guy left
with one another Barclays I had the nice
hook I have no hook on Jets and Giants
that's the only hook I don't know I also
got a hook at the US Open you guys want
to do tennis to get you in the back door
there you go I'm chasing balls down I
worked there I worked at the US Open for
years so we got the hook up we got my
guy shout out big row he opens up the
back gate by P chord seven you walk
right in like one normal name
shout out to Jimmy with the eye and none
of this sounds legit at all it's like at
any moment you could be excuse me sir
yeah are you supposed to be sitting here
that's all real so me and Sarah can I
see your tickets I'm with Chrissy yeah
so are you theoretically rolling the
dice could the hammer come down on you
just got bounced out of the owner that
for the MSG no that was up and up I
could get you the hammer could come down
at the U.S open we could get we could
get a federal investigation there that
could happen to anybody over there yeah
they're real highfalutinous those are
federal charges either that ain't New
York no no the U.S open I swear to God
I'm literally telling you I'm sending
you a GPS coordinate on a map and you're
walking in through Flushing Meadows Park
through an unlocked gate that's what
we're doing for that but you know it but
it all but we know the guys there you
grease them you can I can get you win to
eighth I can get you into a 500 800
match if you just grease security guard
50 bones that I could that I can again
pinpoint accuracy we used to do that
when we were kids we would Greece there
was a guy in the neighborhood that
worked security at MSG and what he would
do is is we would go we got into
multiple um Stanley Cup games we got
into a couple of Knicks playoff games
what you would do is he said where he
was working he worked out you know
whatever section and this and that you
would get through because you can walk
into MSG you only start scanning there
used to be a time where they would only
start scanning tickets when you got to
your actual section you would scan and
walk in now you got to go through metal
detectors they gotta there's another
line of security but back then he worked
there and all he would do is say he
would say listen just [__] print
anything out print any all I got to do
is take your piece of paper and he had a
but it was like not as um in
computerized back then sure he would
have a button in his like a thing that
would play back what the sound yeah and
so it would just do that have him go
scan so his boss as if they were there
could just see but half the time his
boss wasn't even there he would just go
like that you would just walk in we saw
and then we had no seats we would just
walk around the stadium all day and then
we knew the concession guy one of the
concession guys also lived in the
neighborhood he would give us you know
at a certain time not right away but at
a certain time you know here's some hot
dogs here's some popcorn here's some
soda you know he just take the Caps off
because you know you don't want to
you're not allowed to throw the Caps we
would just walk around with you know get
everything for free but that was another
time we don't we don't get that anymore
now but now I get them free Yeah Yeah
Yeah Chris he did well the Mets connect
is I [__] friends with the owner's
son
yeah if that is Premiere shout out Josh
shout out to Cohen family one of them I
don't know man he's like this is Jack's
Cohen he owns the Mets I was like yeah
yeah no it's Josh shout out Josh come on
Steve Cohen shout out uh Alex Cohen
really the Cohen family is is I've never
met people like that are so kind like
that that you know they do so well but
you know you get that he's got a little
bit of cash
I know I'm [__] trying to do an
investment column on my patreon I should
just ask Steve Cohen what the [__] to do
no yeah you're like take your first
billion you're like wait what excuse me
um but uh but me but but buy a third
baseman
great people to come I know I [__] I
can't I can't get anybody from my
daughter's birthday get Pete Alonzo they
had a [__] tattoo with [__] pinata
are you wait hold on when's the birthday
coming up her birthday her my daughter's
birthday parties in two three weeks what
we got we got a taco truck it's Barbie
themed we got a Barbie cake at the house
it's at the house shout out Mark's bakes
up on Staten Island they're doing shot
you pay for anything yeah you are such a
guido dude Mark's bake shop on Staten
Island Pueblo taco trucks um they're
they're doing it for us and all their
Affiliates and all their Affiliates and
all subsidiaries best fish tacos you've
ever seen your goddamn life that taco
truck play blows pueblance
um and uh and Mark's bake shop um I mean
unbelief makes great German chocolate
cake it makes you you know rethink you
know the Nazis is that what you're
having don't look at me
[__] wrote me is that what you're
having for the cake a German chocolate
cake no what you what that's classy well
well here's the very underrated the
German chocolate I love it let me say
that coconut and chocolate delicious
German chocolate cake shout out Rudy's
Bakery
um in Ridgewood they make an
unbelievable German chocolate cake
Hometown cooking yeah
um they uh this has been a 40 minute
plug so far we're all just now
yeah
I also want to shout out Joe and John's
Pizzeria some of the best pizza in
Richard
um so how many people you got coming to
the party how many kids how many adults
so here's the issue Jazz and I spoke
about it you know so want to keep it
small just the Friends this ain't gonna
be small just a friend taco truck I know
best fish tacos you have everything in
your life you guys are invited now thank
you friends family have me working there
she said I'm in the dunk tank she said
she wants to keep it 15 20 she wants to
invite the class we're at 60. you're at
six six kids sixty sixty people but we
got the pool open that's why Armando
open we got the pool open we gotta we're
hoping for a nice day if not we move the
party into the sun room we have a good
time the thing is with my how many kids
how many kids her class so her class and
then and then so she's got about eight
eight uh she's got about 18 in her class
and our parents invited too parents yeah
you gotta have a chaperone so the
parents are invited and then and then
and then you know the kids in Jasmine's
family which is probably another 18.
okay so Hachi Machi you know what I
don't know what you want to do throwing
down a couple of bucks hiring a
lifeguard for that right now no we did
no yeah yeah no we that last year yeah
we had the same party last year but it's
funny I was I was telling because it was
pouring rain right me and my dad we
walked these four or five blocks and
it's we're soaking wet appointment we're
having a good time we're talking about
the game we're laughing my dad's like I
think I'm getting a fever and and I
swear he was asking me for time he was
like you got any like Tylenol Cold and
Sinus or anything on my temperature's
going up I was like we're literally
getting belted with freezing rains it's
like I know it's not good and so this is
the one yeah and so and so where I mean
soaked like we jumped in in the pool we
get we're we're again walk these four or
five blocks where one foot outside of
the parking garage where we're gonna be
underground and get out of the rain my
dad goes look at this holds up his right
hand he was holding an umbrella the
whole time I forgot he had a [__]
full umbrella the whole time he's like I
forgot I was having so much fun talking
and I was like well now we're both good
he's gonna both gonna get pneumonia yeah
that's true
oh my God by the way Fiji one I know you
guys Target but this is this is glass of
course right this is yeah yeah that's
how we do we had to level up we did we
got the new studio no more Dannon no way
we were like uh we were like some Puerto
Rican company weren't we yeah it was
like El agua or something yeah
it was the life one it was called like
something like uh pure pure Pure Life
yeah which blew up during the pandemic
that's all you get your hands off yeah
but Fiji is you know you know what's
going on
dash yeah it's a write-off too this is a
little bit of a reverse but what is the
follow-up on the uh the communion
situation do we want to talk about it so
let's do the communion okay so the
listener out there we did Chrissy chaos
uh that's gonna be coming out that's
already out I think it's out already on
Tuesday all right so there you go there
you go so everybody knows the deal so
everybody knows the deal so what
happened was I didn't want his kid to
get community I didn't want to get him
straight to Hell door yeah I saw one
documentary I'm thinking I can't you
know subscribe and then I'm talking to
other parents and they're like yeah we
none of us go to church it's been our
Traditions commute you live on Staten
Island you have to if you don't do
communion you guys won't be Jewish
you're going to get investigated by the
[__] NYPD over here they're like what
he's not doing communion so you know
there's no Christmas lights yeah you got
trouble trouble so so they the boys here
they convinced me the garbage boys
convinced me they're like well you got
to do communion so I said I gotta find
the PATH so I called the priest I called
him right then and there and we really
said it just for inclusion purposes yeah
whatever anybody's beliefs are you know
whatever they are but if everybody in
the class is having a community first of
all right she goes without she goes to
Catholic school that's the issue I was
talking to somebody I thought she was
like I'm hearing some weird you know
private schools she's in a Quaker School
no yeah but then you're like yeah she's
in Catholic school so she's gonna be
sitting on a [__] bench while
everybody's partying yeah the kids are
going to be coming in with stacks of
cash Monday morning she's gonna have
nothing nothing and that's the thing is
I was like you know yeah some of my
peers that I talked to like oh when I do
Catholic stuff anymore sometimes I could
be impressionable I'm like oh yeah me
either but then it's like I'm sitting my
kid to a Catholic school so it's like
got to do the tradition so I call the
priest and he goes I said grease them
what did what did first of all when we
left what did you say to to Jazz so I
said to Jazz because again did you
mention my name because I'm afraid I am
genuinely afraid of her I seen her on
the spin bike yeah she can move yeah
yeah I I didn't I didn't mention
anything I said listen I said hey how
you doing
how you doing
I said listen can I you got a minute and
she was like uh oh and I was like I was
like no it's all good worst thing you
can say to your girl that's stupid I go
um I said uh I got a minute I should I
said listen I said I've rethought this I
said I really think we should have our
daughter do communion I think he's gonna
feel left out whether our beliefs or our
beliefs on this are irrelevant it's
tradition I don't want her to feel left
out and then she was like all right she
was like we can she was like I'm not
gonna this is all on you I'm not getting
involved you I'm not I'm not you got to
handle it I'm not going to scramble and
do you have to do it now you have to get
the dress you have to do everything you
you have to do it so I was like fine so
you know right you handle that get in
the communion well here's well the issue
is the issue is is not the issue but
when we got to that point I said she got
a Yankee Jersey yeah a couple a couple
hours later I texted her three dresses I
found on Amazon and she calls me she
goes I'll handle the dress yeah she was
like you're not we're not getting our
daughter's communion dress on Amazon my
first thought was Amazon yeah if I'm
being honest with you what else I just
literally put in the search bar
communion dress seven-year-old tomorrow
immediately I found what [__] great
one for 29.99
the pool I can't get a dress now so so
she um so so anyway so she gives me the
okay so I had a great neighbor because
now we got to think about communion
parties right that's what I'm thinking
of the our great neighbors like listen
instead of doing all that why don't you
just combine it with my daughter
classmate of her great we'll do it
together and of course I'll throw him
some cash for that well sure we'll do it
we'll do it together this way we'll
honor the girls together it's not like
it's all it's all of them yeah yeah so
great jazz is cool with that too is that
it next door or your place that is he
doing it that's his place he's doing it
yeah so he's like you know take care of
it yeah so the whole Community does that
a lot I think I had mine with like
friends or my cousins it's fine it's not
a birthday taco truck what are you gonna
do no I won't be honest he owns a
restaurant so we're gonna do it it's his
restaurant
Don Cheech on Bay Street in Staten
Island one of the best restaurants let
me tell you something Don Cheech on
Staten Island Bay Street new restaurant
open last year's the best salmon you
could find in the island Don Cheech
Staten Island go check it out I love it
yeah so you're gonna do it at the
restaurant you're like the Small
Business Bureau it's not an island we're
gonna do it at the restaurant yeah
the only thing that the only thing that
we're you know I'm gonna take a couple
of lumps for but my mom is forgiving is
because it's at his place he already had
his family he's got there's not a
there's not enough rooms so we can only
bring Mom
grandpa and grandma that's we can't do
the extended invite to the ants uncles
everybody what we can possibly do is in
the next weekend do a separate communion
party just for the family that's what
we're thinking of doing do that at the
house we could do that at the house but
we can't the actual communion that
coming to church we don't have enough
seats you know it's in the church in the
church they could come I'm saying the
party I just had to throw a big blowout
I can't invite 40 members of my family
that's the only issue but my family said
they're okay with that they understand
the main thing my mom is like that she's
getting the communion my mom's like I
just I need your mom had a beat is it I
need her to eat Jesus so it's mostly
going to be the other girl's family yeah
like that yes but again and the other
kids in her school weren't be there
won't be there no they'll be at their
own communion parties so it's fine it's
no problem and then I call the priest
that's the big the last thing the school
I call them they say listen you know you
got it there's a couple of documents you
got to get us got it one two three you
know she has she been going to church
you know you say yeah but of course she
has of course she has why the hell not
yeah they said I have to go to Sunday
mass last Sunday which I did got it
stamped by the priest I got the stamp
and then and then I got to go this
Sunday get this receipt get one more
stamp and I got yeah I'm good so we're
good on that but then you know it comes
down to well you know there was some
things missed and then so I say call the
priest great guy and I said what's up
father I said you know here's my
situation I'm I I rethought about having
my daughter get communion you know I had
some things going on but I want to go
ahead and do it and he goes he goes I
don't know it's a little late and I was
like tell me what the path you know what
that means that I know so he goes tell
me what the path is how heavy is this
envelope gotta be to get it he goes he
goes uh he goes well she had how she
made her Penance I said no he goes
he was like all right he's like I might
be able to get up you know private
penance
he goes I got a whale
he goes she's in Catholic school though
right I said yeah she goes to the school
you know your preseason goes okay he
goes um he goes man he goes there is a
path there is a path there's 500 best
and then he goes and then I just jump in
I say
what if I donated 500 to the church she
goes I like that yeah he goes he goes we
can do that and then I said um and then
I swear you guys think I'm lying but I
said I said I'm also you know I do
stand-up comedy I said I have a big show
in New York Philip and then you you know
I know you're in the New York area I
said I got Radio City I'm doing Radio
City have you ever went to the radio
City goes of course Radio City sure sure
I go I got a show there September 23rd
it's sold out but I can get you
September 22nd so but it's sold out I
can get you two tickets he goes yeah
I'll take four tickets that's what he
said he goes he goes yeah four tickets I
said so so I dropped that envelope
Market included on these what are we
talking I dropped the five hundo in an
enveloped him on Sunday
tickets I told him you know he's got an
assistant they'll be emailed a week
before and she's in line baby she's in
line for that communion we got the dress
came the shoes and we did it Staten
Island Miracle right there Money Talks
man he talks in a couple of passes the
Radio City that's it and you're saving a
couple of bucks on a party time the
party I mean we're you know I'm spending
it on the taco truck for the birthday
party the week before I mean May's gonna
hit me big so that's right so her
birthday is the week before her
birthday's the week before that so
that's perfect I got bet because I don't
I don't want to get in your head I was
full disclosure I was a little concerned
with that joint party that's going to be
real heavy on the other kid you don't
want her to feel left out but if she's
having if you blow it out the week
before at the house also she's not gonna
have any problems these are Italians I
believe they're gonna bring her in she's
gonna make her the Stars no no they're
Dominicans oh Dominicans okay and I got
my town and Puerto Rican side but the
Dominicans and Puerto Ricans although
known historically enough beef not in
this circle Dominican supporter weekends
are allies they're allies yeah and I'll
bring her in oh look how pretty yeah
yeah as my father says Ah same thing
different bus stop
[Laughter]
somebody don't talk like that just
kidding I'm just kidding around oh wow
you should date Tampa Tony and Tutti
would be I mean that'd be the new Jay-Z
Beyonce right there talk about a match
made in heaven oh my God then oh my God
that kid would be born with a cigarette
and a limp
I can't believe we never thought of that
but but yeah so so we got a good uh you
know there's a catfish your dad with
dirty pictures [__] love it I don't
know if we'd like the end result of that
but but
um but but yeah so so uh so yeah so it's
all working out but I got a big I got a
big May that's why you know we got
Buffalo sold out we got Albany so we got
some tickets left on the table in Ithaca
and that's why I need you to come I need
you to come in Ithaca uh which is uh I
believe it's this this Saturday this is
Ithaca Friday's uh Buffalo Sunday's
Albany Saturdays Ithaca this this week
um we got uh we got may we got the
communion we got the daughter's birthday
then we got my mother's birthday it's my
mom you gotta also blow that out got a
nice family you know nice dinner you got
Mother's Day coming up on the fourth
Mother's Day mother's birthday this is
back to back you get hit it's what it is
what are you doing with that now I got
the baby's birthday the little one's
birthday then I got my stepson's
birthday so we're getting this is all
may may into June we get hit bang we get
banged up the only thing the only time I
get a little something back is Father's
day I get a little something back but I
probably wind up paying for that in some
[__] weird way because I pay the
credit card bills yeah I mean I don't
think your daughter's breaking open her
[__] piggy bank yeah well it's never
too late to invest Warren bro uh Warren
Buffett brought his brought his uh first
stock at 11. so she's got to pipe it up
that's what dude that's a that's a
stretch right there damn how many shows
you doing today
it's it's you know Buffalo we we got two
I smartened up if the guy did one and
then Albany we sold out two months ago I
didn't add one so now I'm I'm sitting on
[__] money in Albany which now I
didn't realize I need it but after the
after the check came in for the resizing
of the pool the outdoor grill and the
losses we took from on the communion oh
man you got the plate spinning over
there we should have added we should
have added a second show and then I've
told if any of the fans from the
christianos podcast and hey babe podcast
no I told you I've been open about I'm
taking the summer off well that's
changing
I'll be at work Monday morning yeah I'm
adding dates we're open for business
yeah I'm gonna take my two weeks off
like the American that I am and then I'm
back out there
okay let's talk about rocket money
liftoff rugged money yeah let's go let's
talk about saving money with rocket
money a lot of Americans think that they
only have about 80 worth of
subscriptions going that's what I think
but you know what it is what about 200.
two bills coming out the door do
yourself a favor get over to Rocket
money if you don't know how much money
you're spending on subscriptions then
you need rocket money that can help you
out cancel the scripture right there and
walk away easy peasy yeah guys it's fine
it's uh it's fantastic rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels unwanted subscription monitors
your spending and helps you lower your
bills all in one place quick and easily
view all your subscriptions and cancel
any you don't want a touch of a button
this whole time I was paying for dildos
in a month club I had no idea I wasn't
even getting the packages Rocky money
even puts your expenses into categories
and alerts you if anything looks off
it's budgeting and easy mode those five
dollar charges can seriously add up
download rocket money today and take
control of your finances stop throwing
away your money cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
garbage that's rocketmoney dot com slash
garbage dragonmoney.com what are you
doing for the Mother's Day in your mom's
thing just that's a nice dinner so what
is is so so you know one time a couple
years ago I tried to get away with the
combo Mother's Day birthday party didn't
work don't doesn't work so we won't do
that again but so now what we'll do what
we're gonna do because now I got because
now I got this is a situation where I
got you know Jasmine the mother of my
kids my own mother and my stepmother and
Jasmine's mother all wait your dad's
remarried my dad's remarried yeah my
parents got divorced when I was about
three years old so we got my stepmoms in
for a month with with Dad Jasmine their
mom together yeah they're both in
together Jazz's mom my mom and Jazz so I
gotta come I gotta do something nice for
the moms I got four moms last year what
I did actually turned out to be a nice
hit Jesus Christ yeah you are a
different level you should just see if
the Knicks are playing that night that's
what you gotta do smaller couple it
takes yeah dude bring her to the game
yeah last year we did what we actually
did we did actually a mother's brunch
that we did at the house you're the only
dude I know with four moms
we did a Mother's Day brunch out the
house I we did nice spread shout out
Violet seller on Highland Boulevard
great they said nice spread um it's
actually a great great great little
thing they got over there
um Violet seller we did a Mother's Day
brunch we had it catered in the house we
set it up smart we set it now so we have
a gazebo Jazz dressed up the Gazebo
Knight gazebo yeah we put a nice gazebo
we made it a nice kind of wine and dine
dinner my mom was late she sent two
hours of traffic she was up at uh her
boyfriend at the Times house all the way
up there in Bedford New York so she was
a little late but we kept the food nice
and warm for her and we had a great
little Mother's Day brunch it was
affordable
um so this year I got to think of what
we're going to do here for Mother's Day
the good news is this year I got tamper
Tony with me the secret weapon he
usually comes thinks of something nice
they're gonna get along the mom and
Tampa Tony now Tampa Tony had to sit
down with everybody everybody well when
I at first what there used to be
fireworks a little bit then when my
oldest daughter was born when you know
when that baby came he had to sit down
with the whole family he said we got to
let bygones be bygones we can't we can't
let the we can't let the baby feel any
of this
your backyard's creeping into an event
space a little bit of an adventure
dude I'll tell you it's another another
Revenue stream that I might need
diversification diversification
year when you come home
I'm gonna try to get I'm going to try to
get a picture of my dad with my mom and
stepmom on his lap put a thumbs up what
would you say you're all in for on the
birthday party rough figure four grand
that's it on the birthday the taco truck
is three whoa I told you best fish it's
not a cash truck when you get there
right not everybody's paying no no no
that's all it's all inclusive no this
you come to my house nobody pays I mean
I got you know somebody put it in the
driveway you're gonna bring it in the
backyard no they put it in the driveway
okay yeah or right in front of the house
yeah let me make sure I I think I'm
saying it right it's Pueblos Pueblos uh
taco truck can you throw a quick Google
I don't want to [__] it go to Pueblos
taco truck I want to make or La Puebla I
want to make sure because Mark's bake
shop I know off the back of my hand
that we got at Pueblos Taco is it do you
see it the kids Futures riding on New
York New York face to Pueblo Taco
Cholula Taste of Puebla that's what it
is Taste of Puebla taco trucks
um is that that's the taco truck right
yeah it looks like a taco truck Taste of
Puebla that's what it is Taste of Pueblo
on Instagram great actually hooked up
through Alex Cohen uh Mrs Mrs Metz hit
this up taste the pub this is if it's
good enough for the cones it's good
enough for me yeah so Taste of Pueblo
taco truck they'll be coming in so we
got we got we're in we're in the for
three grand for that with the original
let me be on let me put a little uh
because the way they started you were
talking about a celebrity dropping for
this thing well I can't make it you
think I need a celebrity oh you that's
what you would kind of mentioned really
you started talking about the birthday
party
to come by oh that I was gonna get
somebody to come by oh the Easter Bunny
no I don't know you said that in the
very beginning you started telling the
story did I I thought you did pick up I
didn't I didn't remember saying that get
Chaz to come shake a couple of hands cut
that
yeah yeah yeah I get a chance to come by
to a couple of lines from Bronx Tale for
the kids oh my God yeah I'll put them
all in the bathroom
that would be [__] awesome yeah so so
I got so we're in for three on that I'll
taste the Pueblo taco truck you know we
need booze we got adults there sure
let's say we're in for another five
there okay we got it we we hire shout
out shout out my girl Sandra the
cleaning lady we'll have Sandra the
cleaning they come and she does 250 for
parties but she does a full cleanup so
we're at 37.50 okay we got um we got the
Lifeguard which we'll have I told her I
told her I'll give her 200 for three
hours no problem easy
then we got lickety-split ice cream
shout out there coming in I got them
coming by you are they walking billboard
I
mean the ice cream truck you can't have
you know you need ice cream what are you
gonna do you got it you got ice cream
truck they're gonna probably hit us for
I would imagine a hundred a hundred for
an hour maybe 200 for the hour we got
the kids get let them ice cream sure got
Mark's bake shop who gives me a deal but
we still gotta you know I mean let's
let's I mean it's a Barbie it's a
custom-made Barbie cake for my beautiful
little girl we're gonna that's gonna be
about five yeah it's really about five
five hundred and three shout outs yeah
yeah yeah what about the rest of the
food and two plugs on Rogan so we got it
so we got the taco truck but that that's
a good point you bring up because now we
got apps I gotta have apps you can't be
feeding little kids fish tacos nobody
nuts no well you are crazy so the good
thing about taste the good thing about
Taste of Pueblo which I think separates
them from the recipe you said the name
too many times there's there's a meter
going oh sorry
because they do offer a good kids man
you so that but again we need the chips
we need the salsa my dad loves salsa you
know you're not gonna I'm not gonna have
to kind of a cheese board I was gonna
say I'm not gonna have tampantoni now
it's not a cheese board out there
so all in and then and then of course
you know my daughter's birthday present
so all in I think I think we're gonna be
over four I think we're gonna be over
four okay yeah you're well over yeah I
thought she wants a scooter so you know
we got it we gotta get her a scooter and
you know uh so that and then of course
you know it can't just be that but then
what I like to do is I I also in this
budget if I'm gonna drop some cash on my
daughter I get her what she wants but
then I put in money to her 529 savings
account you know Chrissy Finance 529
savings plan that's the best if you got
kids in my opinion that's the best way
to to save for the children gets 100 tax
free when they and you can use it all
for school so I throw some cash all in
there and then that's it and then we get
hit and that's that's that's the
birthday we get hit for the communion
and then we'll get hit for Mother's Day
and that you know with all said and done
all the money I make this week in
Buffalo Ithaca and Albany should be
going to these parties in May there you
go really running through the [__]
ringer you are running through the
ringer but that's you know it's got a
full life my friend it's gritty chaos
yeah you know you really truly is man on
and off if this ain't an act no he comes
in like a tornado and you're just in his
life I'm giving him life advice on how
to Christen his daughter that's why I'm
on blood pressure medicine so I'm 28.
122 over 73 yesterday's reading by the
way I want to give a quick shout out to
my arteries
Dr Jenkins out there in Bay Ridge yeah
yeah shout out doctor [__] his
arteries do you have this thing at the
house the little finger thing yeah I'm
consistently 98 oxygen to a hundo and
then my resting heart rate's good 65 I
do burpees every day now 100 burpees
that's the key where are you doing the
blood pressure on that thing too I got a
cuff Omron blood pressure cuffs out
there I want to get one of those no get
that get a blood pressure cuff and get
the uh get the get the pulse oximeter
you're good to go okay and the
intermittent fasting zero fasting Ops
the one I use
I like it you are [__] it's amazing I
mean Chrissy fasting I need a new ad guy
dude you're having for the summer
where's the two-week vacation the
two-week Orlando we're going down there
for uh Jazzy's on Mom's uh big birthday
or bashed so we got an Airbnb we got an
Airbnb I'm doing Disney no what we're
doing is
yeah they didn't want to do this thing I
took the kids to Disney in L.A last last
year we went to Anaheim Disney which
people's [__] on they liked the Anaheim
Disney they loved it really okay we're
going I got an Airbnb I got an Airbnb
that's unbelievable it's shout out to
the confection Airbnb shout out to
Airbnb I mean it's Airbnb you've never
seen anything like it I think it's in
Lakeland uh Florida or in that area I
mean we're talking Acres acres and Acres
you do not leave this Airbnb this Airbnb
is next now it cost me 10. I dropped 10
which I was told Jazz don't worry about
it my family's gonna give you money back
friend I'm not expecting it sure I
dropped 10 easy I said you guys buy the
groceries and I dropped that I don't
even it out
yeah they're a [__] Key Food I mean
you can't spend ten thousand dollars at
Key Food in your whole lifetime so 8 500
a turkey yeah yeah yeah so so I um I so
I got uh so we got that coming up that's
that's two week VK and that'll be nice
because my dad lived in Tampa so he'll
drive and meet us in Orlando
two hours two hours and then uh and then
yeah and then August we're gonna hang
out a little August and then we got the
Borgata coming up late August not on
Celia but we're gonna do two at the
Borgata there you go man there you go I
gotta do they want to take that right
back make that right back and then and
then in September again we pick it up
again we hit the road heavy and then uh
I'm gonna try to do my my special in
December and then the plan is 2024 we're
gonna try to take you know four or five
months off from the road okay that's
where we got to get this podcast we got
to get the merch we got to get the
scratch all up over there Chrissy chaos
patreon.com Christy comedy I'm stalled
sweat oh yeah
[Applause]
conversation with this dude yeah
dude we did we recorded the podcast the
other day we can fully get in the car to
go somewhere four minutes goes by I
gotta call hey I just want to thank you
for coming in doing a podcast yeah I
appreciate it I got 58 questions for you
yeah we got some issues
but that's all right what can you do
right I love you man
um but I love it we got to get to some
[__] garbage questions from the
patreon gang as you know when you join
the patreon we will answer your question
on the air uh it's just the best way to
do a patreon gets the first crack at it
because let me be honest with you
they're goddamn homies all right and we
got Christy D in here and we got Christy
D answer call I feel some of the
questions this is one's from this it's
kind of funny because we do get a lot of
people from history hyenas and you had
the names so I get a lot of we get a lot
of this is on Arturo de choro which I
probably comes from enjoy the truth
sounds like yeah I mean let's we're
wearing the patreon OG's you know 100
yeah it's a shame you guys went away
what can you do
be nice to have some of that scratch
right now
all right this one's our Tour de churro
10 homie is it garbage in my all my job
offers surf and turf dinners on
Wednesday for 32 smackaroos plot twist
it's crab and a burger
that's a bad surf and turf yeah surf and
turf has to be a steak and lobster no it
has to be it surf and turf has to be a
steak and lobster steak and shrimp I'll
let you take it away shrimp I'll give
you that's like Outback wizard let me
tell you they weren't serving crab and
burgers at that owner's Suite in MSG
Chris Rock did not have a play to that
me and my dad did but not him so I yeah
that that's garbage to me yeah yeah
where was the last time you went
slumming it somewhere in a restaurant
where you're like this is kind of shitty
but we're going anyway I took the family
Outback a few days ago a few days ago
they love it the blooming onion my
daughter goes wild for it they love it
blooming onion I like the uh the
Applewood uh chicken sandwich I actually
go with the chicken sandwich in Outback
it's very good there you go you like a
nice lady I like a nice lady yeah I like
that shout out the Outback on uh on 18th
Avenue in Bensonhurst that's the one we
go to that's where you go yeah table in
the back they know us yeah the
pumpernickel bread it's phenomenal warm
with butter if they don't if it doesn't
come out more my husband throw it back
in there and warm it up
you leave a nice tip oh I told you we go
you know the the standard is 30 I go 40.
and you put that on the card or you do
cash for the tip I tried as best I can I
try to do cash or they don't got to pay
the taxes on it as much as long as Uncle
Sam doesn't know and if they recognize
me I go 50. you gotta go we talked about
gotta go big gotta go heavy it's only
happened two three times for me but you
got it you gotta come correct yeah uh
this one's just funny this is from Kim
Hightower any of the female members in
your family know how to drive a pickup
truck
hmm
uh pickup truck a pickup truck I mean
that's just a great driver sure my
Jasmine my mom wouldn't
Panic though my mom would be like I
can't do this I used to drive a pickup
all the time she's working the dock
Jasmine knows how to use a table saw she
was cutting up the wood to make Jasmine
from scratch made for our daughter's
party a a homemade Barbie Photo Booth
she cut the wood pieced it together yeah
she was with a table saw out there with
glass goggles on and uh you own a table
salt you get it from somebody showing
the contractor
he let us have the table saw she did it
it was great she Built This Bar it's
beautiful this Barbie photo booth there
you go uh that's all right yeah
customers Barbie Photo she literally I
swear to God she literally was building
that thing that she built that Barbie uh
uh photo booth with the table saw and I
went to the supermarket and got us fresh
avocados
and got dinner started yes that's what I
did I put that apron on I started
sucking [__]
um
uh get the cookies in the oven right no
uh all right let's see here this is uh
from finner Canadian 14.50 homie never
had one red is it garbage to make it PB
J and banana sandwich with a hot dog bun
and the whole banana where the hot dog
is supposed to go that's that's a little
erotic I feel you know banana on a hot
dog bun let me say this I'm on record
I've done people I've done everything on
a hot dog bun I've done a hamburger on a
hot dog bun I've done sandwiches on a
hot dog bun putting the banana in there
with the peanut butter and jelly makes
it make more sense can I say that yeah
it makes it make more it fits it fits a
banana yeah and let me throw this at you
if you slice that banana in half and
threw it in a skillet with a little
butter and a little bit of brown sugar
then it's caramelized and delicious then
you got a real banana dog going there
that's it that's a full-blown banana
door I'm just I'm just telling you with
the peanut butter and jelly [__] good
night banana dog good night that's great
how are you doing are you doing PB and
J's at the house are you like an anti
peanut butter house analogy or what are
you doing well I'm not the kids school
you can't have peanut butter but you can
only do sun butter so sun butter that's
what we get so we do sun butter and
jelly that's flour sunflower seed butter
so we can make anything butter now so we
do sunflower butter jelly
um what my man probably pretty good it's
good it's good at home though you know
on snacks at home my daughter loves
Nutella so she goes sun butter Nutella
jelly that's what she likes and the same
sandwich yeah and guess what we brought
home from Italy we went to Sicily guess
what we brought back pistachio butter
pistache we love that in the house no I
don't even that's probably pistachio
they're on a low level run right now
with with flavoring ice cream the whole
thing they're on a big run yes and I
think they're cheating it a little bit
because it has a lot of spamoni
flavoring to it I think they're I think
they're juicing it up a little bit yeah
I'm just gonna say it ain't the same
pistachio ice cream we had them we were
kids that sucked but in Italy in Italy I
think it's real pistachios I got that
from ital I got that in the airport I
got it sure airport in Palermo gate a
that's where all the goodies work
200 bucks you can't have a party without
a clown I got a clown I got people doing
things I got that okay you got a clown a
little bit I got a clown I've got a face
paint that's what I think what I was
leaving do you have somebody coming yeah
yeah you said Celebrity Guess like you
just could have sworn he said they got
the Impractical Jokers coming out there
you go
you got sale with a mustache and glasses
are doing a bit
uh uh you don't have to be impressive
you know this clown
you know the guy uh yeah he's well that
that's one Jazz it's a company they
doing so we don't know him personally
but respected supposedly well respected
he's been you know he's been recommended
okay five other people highly
recommended the the baby likes likes
clowns they don't I don't think they
care let you know really because I would
lose it I think a clown is fine they're
really the face painters with the we
have the same face painting there you go
and then I wanted to do I did this one
year for Delilah's third birthday but
again I didn't clear it we got an
Aerosmith cover band
I didn't clear it with jazz so that's
where the trouble landed but I think
this time if I can clear it with her I
gotta I got pigs I got baby pigs coming
over but we have the apartment in Bay
Ridge and she wasn't prepared for we did
we used to do the birthday parties the
apartment they originated these little
baby pigs Shout Out New York tea cup tea
cuppigs.com in the apartment in the
apartment this was literally the straw
that broke the camel's back and misses
Doubtfire by the way she's gonna leave
you out front you're gonna have a
betting Zoo you had animals in the
apartment I had baby pigs it was cute my
daughter loved it but there I could feel
the anger I could feel the anger and the
disgust and and and it was bad one of
the pigs almost knocked over her
father's urn
took a [__] on the couch yeah I remember
you started this off like yeah just make
problems for myself
that's insane in the apartment in the
apartment yeah dude after this party
you're gonna be like I got a rodeo guy
lets me in the side door yeah yeah
seriously I I got you know and then and
then you know I I said no the only thing
I put the cabbage on is jazz was saying
you know we got so many people out there
we got we got the new floors in the
kitchen let's get a porta potty so they
go to but I said I can't do that they
got to come in no yeah you can't do it I
can't do a porta potty they got it I
can't do that because then who knows
when the hell is that okay tailgate yeah
I said no we're gonna get jammed up two
three days there they can't get a truck
out that's in the backyard yeah that's
the last thing I need I I don't need my
dad you know eating you know Pueblos
taco trucks and that's sitting there for
three days
we gotta wrap it up man ladies and
gentlemen Mr Kristen Stefano Mr chaos
Chrissy chaos podcast hey babe podcast
on the road right now got the theater at
Madison Square Garden coming up at the
end of the summer and you got Radio City
physical sold the [__] out let's do it
baby and we're 55 at the theater in MSG
so tickets are moving look we still got
five months on the boat you gotta go the
good seats the good seats are almost
gone you gotta go get them Chris D
comedy.com for tickets look at them
we're gonna throw some merch up there
too
we need it we need it we're getting
Sakura's merch guide
[Music]
you are an idiot
oh by the way I'll try to give myself a
quick shout out moved up on himself out
now uh quick plug Christy comedy uh
Platinum Delta folks
I'm going
I it's a first class business class
ticket all around the world no matter
what I buy have these parties at the
lounge at JFK what are you doing that
Apex Lounge is all right I know you're
nuts I know you're sneaking 15 Puerto
Rican kids in there
eating all the egg bites yeah uh what do
you got for them uh we [__] love you
we're all over the road we also have the
merch drop uh are you garbage.com all
tickets to their live shows we're
getting ready to announce the second leg
of the tour this year get those tickets
get that merch we'll see out there baby
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week peace